the man behind air Mars and nectar has
announced a multi-million pound
investment in a retail technology
venture whose clients include Marks &
Spencer Topshop and Uniqlo so Keith
Mills who also spearheaded London's 2012
Olympics bit will join the board of a
Cree bow it enables stores to provide
instant targeted offers to customers at
the same time ask their receipts based
on their purchases Sir Keith joins me
now so what attracted you to this
business well this is a really
revolutionary company a Cree bow
designed some technology that the retail
markets been looking for for years and
if you go back 60 or 70 years when
customers used to walk into the butcher
shop and the retailers knew all their
customers the holy grail for retailers
is to be able to know their customers
what their needs are at the point of
sale and a Cree bow provides a system to
do just that
so what's his point of difference
compared with other schemes of that for
example our Tesco Clubcard or whatever
so cub card collects the information
about what customers are buying and and
then sends them offers those offers come
three months later can't do it in real
time now I could create an agree webcam
but yeah so literally at the
point-of-sale if you've gone into a
supermarket and for the first time
you've bought a pack of Pampers it's a
good chance you've just had a baby and
so the offers that you'll get and the
communications you'll get at the
point-of-sale
in real time will be about babies and so
and there's a lot of hard evidence to
suggest that that will drive loyalty in
a pretty strong way the retailers in the
UK like MS and Waitrose that have been
using this system for a few years now
are making massive massive amounts of
money off of the incremental sales that
they drive and what about the team
behind it tell us something about them
well dr. Hasan [ __ ] is an extraordinary
individual actually born in Egypt
educated in the UK brought up in the UK
double first at Cambridge went off and
did computer science in Japan in
Japanese is the brains behind this
business and this is the the products
that are being put into the market right
now by a credo Creepo are really the
first of a new generation of products
which will revolutionize the way and
retail the way retailers communicate
with their customers and it's uks
uk-based and entirely you came
in reading its UK owned we employ 40 odd
developers adding reading and the reason
for this investment is to enable them to
develop more products and to take a
Creepo globally and with targeting the
US in particular
so taking global how do we compare in
the UK in terms of engendering loyalty
among customers compared with other
developed economies we're at the leading
edge I mean when I developed airmiles
actually back in the 1980s of the first
customer loyalty program and more
recently nectar which is now actually 15
years or so old we've led the way around
the world and and that's why we're so
excited about a creeper because again
British technology and British know-how
is leading the way in retail and you
know there are some pretty sophisticated
systems around the world but we've
always taken the lead among your many
other hats you're also the backer of our
cibele Ainsley's America's Cup challenge
coming up in May how we're going to do
very exciting we've been trying to win
the America's Cup this is a competition
that we started in 1851 and we've never
won so for 160 plus years we've been
trying to win it and this time we've
been Ainsley Martin Whitmarsh the XS CEO
of McLaren and an incredible team of
designers and sailors that we have the
best chance ever of returning this
extraordinary traffic back to the UK it
was a main competition the states
presumably the Americans are Oracle the
team owned by Larry Ellison the Oracle
billionaire they've they won it in San
Francisco and you know huge deep pockets
lots of and very smart sailors but I
really feel in Bermuda in May and June
this year we have a real chance of
winning this Cup